Facebook has just bought oculus Amazon
has purchased King streaming company
thanks for talking to us here in the
financial district of San Francisco who
are you and what do you do so
my name is Casey McTigue I am an
attorney but I work in-house at an M&A
financial services
in MA almost it's private the public or
prior to the private transactions we
essentially work with people that just
sold their company anywhere from really
small companies to multi-billion dollar
transactions and any issues that come up
after the deal I'm the one that the
buying company comes to to complain
about or sue or ask for money enterings
like that so it sounds like a pretty
full-on job what's he doing your dance
I'm play video games I do have one son
and he keeps me busy most of the time
now but whenever he's in bed for that
hour between bed for him and bed for me
is usually video games
what's up games you play play world
warcraft although that's been a lot more
part-time than it used to be I just
finished the new Call of Duty single air
place if the big sieve 5 fan and now I'm
playing beyond Earth you've also been a
played World of Warcraft for a long time
as well did you play right at the start
yep I first logged in I think the last
night of beta for vanilla and obviously
off and on since then but from release
up until I was getting close to
graduating college to about two years I
played I would say most days the week
you're pretty savvy with money I heard
that you sold your EverQuest character
one stage for a pretty penny
yep high school I probably played a
little bit more than I should have but
my EverQuest character was number two
best to the best tournament pretty well
geared sold him for about thousand bucks
Wow is that worth the investment you put
into him absolutely not I did it to
break the tether that game had in my
life per hour probably came out to you
know 30 cents an hour so nice hat yeah
so when I first played Warcraft I was
raiding trying to level first through
the past once I didn't have enough time
to do that I tried to find other fun
things to do and I kind of figured out
that anything that's illegal to do here
makes you a lot of money in Warcraft
okay don't go to jail so you know I
wasn't the first one to corner the
market on commodities and while but I
certainly figured out how to do it
when they came out with the remote
auction house I bit into that
immediately so when I was at work and
now that I'm not at that job anymore I
can say this but I was definitely
spending some time trading on iron ore
and things like that
flipping it when it came to primetime
rating we always pay more and there's
there's a great website I don't know who
created it it's called the undermine
journal and it's basically a Wall Street
Journal for WoW and you log on to that
they tell you what the prices have been
what's trending up what's trending down
you can then log into your Wow auction
house count and trade on it so I would
buy or usually in the morning when all
the bots had just dumped all of it for
dirt cheap and then you sell it right
before prime time rating starts which is
like I don't know 7:00 Eastern something
like that what were the most profitable
commodities anything that well it
depends on the expansion last expansion
I made a lot of money on food and
ingredients to make banquets and things
like that because nobody wanted to
bother and it was really easy to flip so
you wouldn't make money unless you did
it in huge quantities though so what I
would do is and this is the illegal part
in the real world you buy out all the
market you just raise the cap or the
floor on the goods and then it just gets
bought so I didn't actually collect much
in the world I would just flip it what I
found is people in the auction house
would specialize so somebody would
corner in the market index I knew one
guy that made hundreds of thousands of
gold back in rat the blood King just on
wax I was doing or in raw materials
mostly because I found it easier to
measure and didn't take a lot of time
why what was the end goal of this was it
fun was their way of converting this
back into real world money no I never
made any money of that it was just a way
to have fun with the game without
spending four days a week from 6:00 to
10:00 rating
do you think your time in WoW prepared
you at all for the work you do now or
was it more of a kind of a nice little
distraction I actually would say it did
I mean both EverQuest and while did that
a bunch when I was in EverQuest I was a
raid leader for a while I was like 13
years old and I was running groups of 40
people and managing personalities and
trying to get people to do stuff they
didn't want to do and that absolutely
plays into my work now
if I'm talking to investors I have to
try to persuade them something's the
right course of action it helps to
understand where they're coming from
know what they're aiming for in the
transaction and that's all stuff you
pick up I picked it up from video games
there's lots of people here who perhaps
have been playing games their entire
lives you've never maybe know about you
said when your friends is a DA and he
still plays why to this day yeah
I won't i won't out him on camera but i
have a friend who works as a district
attorney he went to law school with me
huge world warcraft guy still raids four
days a week
big Starcraft 2 player got married
recently and his his wedding march was
the terran games you think ulis lee
continued to play games even though you
know kids get older and work gets more
serious is it an important part yeah
absolutely
I used to relax I would probably say
that my days of hardcore rating are done
I don't see a time where I could devote
four days a week to any particular thing
anymore let alone video game but their
way to have fun reconnect with friends
I've got friends in Korea East Coast
Utah here that I wouldn't see it all
otherwise so it's a fun way to connect
what's it like thinking it's ten years
old now that I'm old yeah that the games
that came out in that day were really
changing the industry
it was exciting then and it's great to
see a game like while still going
you